[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that me
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed oh I bet that you'll be fine
without him my name is Joshua Fields
Milburn and I am Ryan Nicodemus and
together we are Voltron I mean we are
the minimalists I think that joke didn't
land last time you used it Oh should we
redo the intro no this is great
this is episode 94 Ryan 94 hard to
believe this is our 94th anniversary
what are we celebrating every week me
that couple Josh yeah that's enough a
happy 94th week anniversary we celebrate
we celebrate by trimesters Max and I
were in our 27th trimester Jesus I'm not
doing the math right I know a trimester
is I mean I know the word trimester
three months well what semester it's one
third of a master
I thought trimester means it's I thought
trimester meant that it's three missed
it means it means three masters right
what the hell is a messenger all right
anyway before we dive into all the
questions that we have about budgeting
which is not a funny subject Ryan it is
we should we should go ahead and do
right here right now we moved this up to
the front because we added a new segment
on to our podcast recently called
weightlifting with the minimalists we
also do a bonus episode where we just do
some weightlifting we'll talk about that
later but right now actually right here
right now
let's talk about what's going on in the
lives of the minimalist Ryan
first off speaking of hilarity ensuing I
have mercury poisoning congratulations
are you laughing at that congratulations
it was funny I told you last last week
we were sitting down I said I just got
my heavy metals test back sigh did Ryan
did this blood and hair and urine
samples mix it all together yeah sturdy
hackers got a weird fetish me and so you
know I've been working on some health
issues over the course of the last
couple years in particular really bad
gut which I've been fixing and
thankfully I got rid of c-diff which
kills 14,000 people a year and I've been
working really hard last year with with
my team of doctors and Chris over at
nourish balanced thrive this is not an
ad it's not a promotion I have to pay
them every single month to do all these
tests and stuff but man he has helped me
get my health back on track and he's
actually helping Jessica our social
media manager she's also on the road
with us he's been helping Jessica get
her health back on track as well I won't
divulge any details on that but I can
divulge my own details here right yeah
we're not gonna talk about our employees
health problem man you should see he's
fixing her toes they're all blood oh
thank gosh she's getting that webbed
foot thing figured out wait what you
have webbed feet I know I'm just
projecting I think Ryan's checking right
now webbed toes oh wait aren't your toes
on your feet are you different yeah but
it's just to my toes that are webbed
uh-huh that's right that's right it's
not the whole foot yes so anyway I heard
it was national joke day recently I
heard a bad joke dude I love me some
jokes man yeah well I heard this joke
about why did ducks have webbed feet I
don't remember the punchline it was so
bad you're laughing more than you would
have been at the punchline you it told
half of a joke it's the worst part it
was it's the like the punchline would
have been acceptable
we're just telling you the punchline
yeah that would've been more acceptable
than telling me a joke and then not
remembering the punchline so so Ryan
asked me what the secret to a good joke
is hey Josh
what what's the timing now I've been
doing this to Ella recently yes and she
doesn't understand jokes for some reason
she'll just start crying when I in a row
her yeah I mean I having some good you
know some she but she she makes some
accidental jokes did I did I tell you
about that remember when that meme was
really was really big Ryan when people
were like looking at other people's
shoes and they would say what are those
what's a meme it's like a gene but but
it's a cultural never mind anyway Ryan
I'm joking yes yeah what are those yeah
that dude
the no before you continue you've got a
unless you're getting ready to tell
you're checking your email right now how
you had no dude I'm checking your face
on your computer yes
all right beautiful so what would you
want me to do know to tell them about
how you when Finella yeah but I'm going
right now in target I can't I can't get
Ryan to even pay attention to me and wow
this is the only reason I actually
record a podcast is so I can get an hour
of Ryan's do you know his email address
I'll give you half I'll give you a half
hour of my time his first email address
was busy guy oh five dude I'm trying to
have some good recommendations and I had
to look up one thing real quick I'm
totally focused on you though I found it
I'm gonna have a great recommendation
for adding value segment it's not a
recommendation P it's just what's adding
value to our lives yeah it may not add
value to yours but that's way later in
this episode okay we're gonna do the
added value segment I was at Target
actually Ella was that target and that
mean was really popular at the time it
probably wouldn't land as well now but
people would go around looking up
people's shoes and if they had you
messed up kicks on they would say what
are those
and it became this whole online meme
well Ella was 2 at the time and and
she's in target and these two college
kids are walking by like down the
shampoo aisle and all of a sudden she
just looks over at them and points at
one of the kids sneakers or college kids
sneakers and just says what are those
and these kids like they just lost it
because yeah it's that the we're
cultural memes are our most prevalent is
with with the youth views and perfect
timing yes not just like right there in
target but like it was in vogue yes
still is kinda yeah actually I had an
idea this morning I was I was at the the
song of this morning which we talked
about a second and I had this idea of
what if you went around and like tried
to it would be sort of this meta comedy
like where you went around and you you
tried to revive old memes that were no
longer in vogue
I would not watch that show it'd be
hilarious if you had the right person it
was like Holly G or something oh yeah or
like Borat right well it's the same that
I know that is Ellijay but um if he put
if he particularly did that bit yeah all
right that would be great yeah or even
if Borat did what are those I mean it
would just be oh my god that'd be so
good yeah anyway um let's see we're
let's blows back oh yeah so she doesn't
get jokes man but but she see you she'll
make these acts as little jokes that
that are like Karlin level funny and she
doesn't even realize and then she gives
imagine we're not what I laugh at her
she's like why are you laughing at me
because hilarity is ensuing Ella that's
why I'm laughing
I remember or I'm imagining Ella like
saying something about the state of our
country and religion she said so she
learned the word Donald Trump that's two
words and she also learned learned the
word tampon in the same day just you
know kids I mean kids are learning so
many new words that it's and so she
heard the word Donald Trump on NPR
come up yeah I don't think Ella has any
particular political views no I think
she likes Donald Trump I think yeah yeah
she well cuz there's that video of her
that I have on Lashley I wanna hear
Donald Trump he doesn't know who Donald
Trump is but anyway this was during the
election election was going on by the
way I tweet all this stuff from her
account she doesn't actually know how to
use Twitter yet but she has an account
called at ella sandwich and so she says
the craziest things we're hilarity
ensues I've got some that I haven't
tweeted yet that I'll pull up here in a
second
because I sort of saved them on my phone
I'm Twitter on my phone so I just save
it in a notes section and whenever I get
to a computer I will tweet it for her
but yeah there was one day where she
just said Donald Trump is a tampon you
could have put anybody's name there
right that would have been hilarious
Trump because it sounds like this
interesting sort of name it's not like
it's political folks no no not on this
one at least if you want to hear weaves
in one politics episode ever it was
called blame you can go back and think
it's episode 37 it's a long long time
ago but we're not doing anything any
politics today we will stay politically
neutral on air yeah yeah what will be
apolitical by the way let's let's look
behind the scenes I'm going for Daffy
Duck doesn't wear pants I like his
attitude what does that look at web feet
typing why are we talking about jokes I
don't know yeah follow at LSM with you
on twitter and there will be plenty of
jokes so here's one for you she just
said what was irresponsible mean she
just looked up at me and said Josh was
irresponsible means I want chemicals on
my body
how funny these are she looked in the
other day she goes Josh I have a special
body and you do not
[Laughter]
oh yeah I sleep with my mouth open
sometime anyway yes and I think my
favorite so far is the when I eat this
chocolate it makes me want to eat more
chocolate all this chocolate makes me
want to eat more chocolate yeah yeah so
so yes I could totally relate with this
kid anyway yeah you can find all it's
it's the way that we catalog her
childhood it's not a scrapbook it's one
tweet at a time anyway I was in the
sauna this morning because I have
mercury poisoning like really really bad
mercury poison so it's it's not so how
do they measure it and wear you out on
the scale so I'm at 96 percentile so
only 4% of the people in the United
States according to the CDC have more
mercury in their blood than me you know
there are two reasons that I do one is I
have these damn metal amalgams in my
mouth which I'm getting I'm getting
those taken out in October I couldn't do
it in middle tour because it would mess
some stuff up
and so we're take we have a bit of a
break in October we're like a three week
break and so I'm going to get them
removed then and they have to do all
these precautions they have to put this
like rubber stopper they have to use all
this extra suction because what's
happening I have to stop chewing gum
right now to which you know me I'm
addicted to gum
yeah it's leeching into my body so
that's part of it but they're able to
measure the difference between the
amalgams and then all the fish that I
eat which I eat way too much fish I have
to stop eating all fish except for Wild
Planet sardines and why Wild Planet
sardines because they don't have any of
the arsenic in the cans yeah they're
because it's like they're farm raised
looks like sustainable farming yes no
arsenic no mercury right Yeah right
and then I also have something called
strontium poisoning oh my goodness my
blood hurried up of strontium I'm pretty
sure they how bad is it
99.9 percent Jesus and so there's 0.1
percent people yeah in the United States
there's like a guy a guy that has more
strontium he's dead
yes yeah and so part of that has Lily
strontium it sounds like some kind of
like comic book metal it's a is I mean
and I so I've I have some lead I have
some cadmium I have some arsenic as well
not high and they're not panic levels
but so I have to do this
chelation therapy but it removes all the
heavy metals but also removes the good
this is the good metals like zinc and
selenium and iron and and so while I'm
I'm sort of purging this from my body
what do they do that it's like hook you
up to like a big magnet machine I wish
it was that easy no I have like these
six different things I'm working with
the team at nourish balance thrive calm
Chris over there is truly amazing if
you're going if you need some sort of
testing blood tests and other stuff he
can order all before you you can he
consult consults with you and again not
an advertisement he's just been so great
working with me over the last year I man
nourish balance thrive calm I couldn't
sing his praises enough he and and
doctor tell me woods over there they're
really helping out with all the stuff
they fixed my gut I no longer have leaky
gut I no longer have c-diff my bacteria
levels are ideal I have I mean did they
do all the stool tests urine tests I've
I've done more tests there's been more
more [ __ ] and piss all over my apartment
because you there at home testing then
than ever before and boy before there
was a lot so writing right now anyway
I've I've I've done so many tests and
finally we had to fix my gut before we
could even do the heavy metals test
because if you have a leaky gut you
there's nothing you can really do to
purge the heavy metal you because it'll
get into your you know and your
bloodstream via the guy and so we
finally did the heavy metals test a year
into it and man I so what is shuttle it
is a metal but there's a supplement I
take because I have my bad back a bad
knees
I take something called strong bone
which has strong
it's a strontium supplement so I have to
obviously stop taking that immediately
and I have stopped taking it but I'm
going through I have to get the amalgams
taken out I'm doing chelation therapy
and part of that chelation therapy is I
so I took niacin this morning I got up
at 5:00 a.m. 4:30 and took a nice and
pill hundred milligrams and I've never
taken niacin before but so today was
your first time first time ever with in
half and then so I can't just go
straight to the sauna which by the way
you go that early and it's like 210
degrees it's great then and but I have
to work out before and then I have to do
an hour in the sauna so I have to work
out before then tec-9 know I'd take nice
and good workout then sauna and as I'm
working out I starts feeling these
tingles like everywhere on the arms my
my head my forehead was just tingling
yeah he's like it burns almost almost
yeah yeah yeah I mean it wasn't painful
at all but it just it's just weird weird
feel it's like my whole body was like
you know when you like sit on it your
hand or something or you lay on your arm
funny and you it starts tingling yeah
whole body was kind of like that falls
asleep dude I've taken it before just I
forget why like just to see the look on
my face that's right no it was like some
part of some cleansing diet I was on or
something sure yeah
and dude mmm there's this there's a show
called workaholics comment I think it's
they're all read about either they're
off the air or they're on their last
season right now but they had this whole
episode where they were taken nice and
and the way that it reacts to their body
is exaggerated like you know because
it's a comedy show yeah but that's
exactly what my body did do like when I
took it it was I had rashes on my arms
like my fanny rashes yeah my face dude
looked like looks like it just looked
like I don't like I had a really bad
sunburn that's what it was it looked
like everywhere was a really bad sunburn
no no I haven't had that but maybe I
took maybe I took too much I could have
been what was yeah I took hundred
milligrams and then I you know so I have
to do this anytime I'm gonna take a
sauna but I'm doing all these other
recovery pills and all this other stuff
basically whatwhat's
happen here what I'm trying to do is
detoxing from heavy-metal poisoning is
really difficult because it gets stored
in your fat cells and then one of the
ways to do it I saw I'm fasting right
now as well so I'm fasting I took niacin
I exercised really heavily a bunch of
pull-ups bunch of push-ups I ran you
don't ever see me running well and then
I got into the sauna for an hour split
by one five-minute shower a really cold
shower in between and and man like the
tingling like I feel super is in doubt
right now actually because I do song as
regularly but man I'm just trying well
I'm trying to sweat it all out and then
I can't eat for at least several hours
after that but then also one of the
things he recommended is doing a
ketogenic diet which we just talked
about on the Nostalgia podcast episode
91 so I'm looking a lot more into the
ketogenic diet because I want to avoid
the keto flu but I started it yesterday
and I said the ketogenic diet yeah I
started it yesterday and I'm not doing
the full 4 to 1 ratio if I had meal
plans like I need something prescribed
to me because like it's tough for me to
be like oh you can have some you can
have some nuts you can have some
sardines you can have some ice cream you
can have a really do ice cream dude yeah
I was listen to that Joe Rogan podcast
with yeah yeah yeah with uh what doctor
what is his name dom D'Agostino yeah
episode 994 yeah and like Mariah and I
were just listening that yesterday we
were walking in and taking that in and
he was like yeah I eat cheese every day
just like a little bit he'll keep me on
the ketosis so it's like I know that if
I start flirting with cheats ya know
like it's what you waster you measure
your blood every day so you know whether
or not you're in ketosis or not if
you're above 0.5 millimolar mil molars
and you are in ketosis here's the thing
that the reason I'm doing it isn't for
like a lot of the benefits some people
do because I get super shredded or
whatever or other people do it because
of cancer prevention because it's it's
or cancer fighting cancer as well so
preventing or fighting cancer or
epilepsy was a big one but the reason
I'm doing it is I'm trying to expel
certain amount of fat you know I have a
relatively low about body fat percentage
but
but the the fat is where all of the
heavy metals are stored in in my blood
right and so I have to get rid of as
much of that as possible so the nice and
will help with that but then fasting and
then doing a ketogenic diet where your
body starts burning fat instead of
burning glucose from carbs and from
protein I'm not doing the four of the
full four to one ratio so four to one
ratio I mean you have four grams of fat
for every one grant combined gram of
carbs and protein so it's a low protein
low carb diet high fat diet and what did
you eat yesterday what was your I had I
so the only sort of carbs that I had
that weren't leafy greens was 1/4 of a
beet and I had a shake or a smoothie in
the morning and there was a bag of kale
in it there was 3 tablespoons of coconut
oil like a a MCT oil or brain octane oil
and an entire avocado oh wow and I can
kill MCT oil this is your smoothie yeah
a quarter of a beat okay and so what's
this the stevia okay a giant tablespoon
of organic cacao powder okay there's no
carbs or sugar in that I notice there's
a few carbs and there's there's no added
sugar and then I had a can of sardines
which is and had all the oil in it as
well
dude that podcast he was like do two can
of sardines is such a treat for me yeah
yeah I was like I want to get to that
point well yeah I love sardines don't
get me wrong yeah I mean they're fine
and then I had for dinner I had
giant salad with a ton of olive oil and
olives and peppers and a big piece of
chicken and that was pretty much it man
nice um are you doing any other
supplements that he was recommending
some I'm using a nap I'm not I've not
done the exhaustion is ketones yeah I'm
looking into that this week but there's
this new app that I'm using to track all
my calories is it went the avatar or one
that you recommend oh it's not the
avatar wanted that one was not as good
nearly as good as this one called My
Fitness Pal which Under Armor now okay
but I've got the free version but you
can track all your calories so I'm still
getting 2300 calories but most of it
from fat and I feel hungry man like
because I know my body's like gimmies
and give me some carbs right I need some
carbs immediately yeah so you mentioned
the the ketogenic flu earlier
yeah keto flu they call it so the keto
flu is basically it's this two-week
period where you're you're basically
withdrawing from carbs you feel like you
have flu yeah and you were saying you
were doing what to minimize it two to
one ratio instead of 4 to 1 ratio
oh gosh you got you and I'm gonna be
playing around with it and if if I get
the keto flu on the road I'm gonna have
to go back to getting some carbs in my
diet and playing around with it tracking
it's gonna be really important but I'll
have back start to sew and she'll
probably put this on her blog minimal
wellness.com as well I'm gonna have her
put together a meal plan for me and if
you I mean if you're interested yeah
something like that
no Mariah we want to we want to do this
diet okay cuz it'll help yeah cuz it'll
help with some of the stuff she has
going on Jim yeah you just want to get
really extreme with it but and by the
way we are not scientists we're not
recommending this thing no in fact we're
not nutritionists yeah even and then
interview was Rogan he was saying how
you know this is not for everyone right
yeah right and and for me like it wasn't
for me either until I knew that I had
this mercury poison and I'm willing to
do I'm willing to sacrifice the carbs so
that I can
may I got to expel this mercury from my
body and
it's so high right now it might my
strontium levels to my strontium level
61 is considered poisonous and I my
strontium level was 8/10 good god 8:10
as it is crazy yeah yeah yeah
so anyway I'm working really hard
whether it's the chelation therapy and
and everything with nourish balance
thrive and Chris's team over there
ketogenic diet removing the amalgams
from my mouth and I've already fixed my
gut before doing this and so amalgams
does that cause strontium poisoning as
well no it's mercury okay yeah and let's
see oh we're moving somewhere but we're
not gonna tell you we're just yet to be
continued this is episode 94 so the next
episode is episode 95 we've been in
Montana Ryan for the last five years now
we've traveled a lot during then
obviously let's give him a little bit of
a teaser we're moving to one of the 40
cities that we had a tour stopped in
this year that's accurate right that is
accurate that's somewhere in North
America the US or Canada we are moving
in one of those cities we're gonna talk
all about it we're doing an episode
called relocating next week episode 95
so go ahead and subscribe to our podcast
if you don't already on iTunes or
stitcher or YouTube or we're the kids
listen to podcasts get Spotify one
Spotify even we're on the NPR one app
for those of you are sophisticated and
have the have NPR as your your main
place to go wherever you subscribe then
yeah well next week we'll be talking
about where we are moving and again it's
one of the cities that we've been on
tour in this past year speaking of tour
Ryan and I are hitting the road once
again when is this episode come out Ryan
this episode comes out on this one's a
budget the 29th oh man so in when two
days Ryan our first tour stopped in
Canada this year we're doing six cities
in Canada starting August August 31st
we're going to be in Toronto now that
might already be sold out by the time
you're listening to this well it sold
out twice already yeah and we've gotten
a larger theater
and this is the last time though we're
not gonna upgrading right really gonna
be in a in a Superdome or something no
do they have a Superdome in Toronto yeah
of course they know where the Superdome
is no the New Orleans Superdome is in
Toronto right we're gonna be in Toronto
and we have six cities in Canada I'll
just go through these really quickly
Ottawa Montreal Vancouver Calgary and
Edmonton some of those are already sold
out less than a dozen or so tickets in
in most of those cities by the time this
comes out so go to Les is now calm its
cause alessa's now tour and from from
Canada we're headed to New York City
we've got three stops in New York two of
those are sold out we added a new stop
in Brooklyn and we've got some special
guests on all of these Philadelphia
we're gonna be I shouldn't say we have
special guests in all of them we have
special guests and a lot of these events
including that the new Brooklyn stop
that we added and then we're gonna head
over to the Mountain States after
Philadelphia and New York City we're
headed to Salt Lake City Denver and
Phoenix some special guests there Denver
might be sold out already and then down
the Texas Austin Texas is sold out
Dallas and Houston there are still some
tickets left Nashville Washington DC
atlanta tampa might be sold out already
and then detroit and milwaukee a bunch
of different cities les is now tour you
can just go to les is now calm and we're
gonna give a live talk about minimalism
and then we're gonna record a live
version of this podcast dish out a bunch
of free hugs answer all of your
questions while you are there as well
all right what else do I have here and
right here right now oh I'm teaching
another writing workshop it's my last
writing workshop of the year I've done
two others this year this one will sell
out it is October 22nd what I've done is
I've taken my four-week online writing
class distilled it down into the the
essence in two plus hours of this live
online workshop you can find the details
of that and how to write better dot-org
I take everything I've learned about
writing all the books that I've read all
the classes that I have taught over the
years about writing and try to give you
at least some pointers some direction on
how
to write better in a two-hour period how
to write better org oh when this comes
out Ryan this this podcast is coming out
mm-hmm
we said the 29th yes man that means we
will already have been at the academy of
podcasting Awards man can you believe we
won so great it was so great Josh just
got up there and drop the microphone I
got up there and said advertisements
suck and drop the microphone yeah
speaking advertisements sucking if you
want to support the podcast keep it
under percent advertisement free you can
head on over to patreon calm the
minimalists or just go to the
minimalists comm and click on the donate
button we're doing a bunch of bonus
episodes and those are free for you all
as well a bunch of bonus episodes for
exclusively for our patreon supporters
so we're doing bonus podcast episodes
we're doing something called
weightlifting with the minimalist where
we dive into a lot of different
questions about the stuff the material
possessions that are weighing you down
we're also doing a patreon exclusive ask
the minimalists anything we're doing
live streams by the way any of that
support if you're supporting us on
patreon none of that money goes to me or
to Ryan it goes to building this podcast
in film studio that we're working on and
we really appreciate your support it's
because of you that we're able to do
this 100% advertisement free and then we
want to thank you by giving you a bunch
of extra meaningful creations over there
on patreon and all by the way if you're
a patreon supporter we'll be the first
to hear about new tour stops that we're
announcing we're headed over to
Australia and New Zealand really soon
but the first people to know about that
are gonna be the folks who listen to
this podcast and support us on patreon
because the tickets will be available to
our patreon supporters before they go on
sale to the to the general public do I
have anything else going on right now
Ryan do you have anything else going on
no min I'm sure probably let's move on
with it we should probably dive in then
to this episode about budgeting I'll
tell you why I've got a pee really quick
let's let's take a quick bathroom break
hey shot I'll dude no way I was gonna
recommend something for son to do but
you you what's your recommendation I
want to hear yours first and I was just
slide over I was gonna tell him to put
some cheesy elevator music in have us
some good music so I've been raving
about this brother Cephas evening that
came out that be much better than
elevator music it is so much better than
elevator music we played a song at the
end of our nostalgia podcast let's go
ahead and insert in the middle of this
podcast they got a song called gotta
have it it's almost the opposite of our
theme song but it's almost satire on
this feeling of of having to have
something like what's that feeling where
you just have to have it right now and
it's almost mocking that in a way but
it's a beautiful song so while we take a
bathroom break have a listen to gotta
have it by brother Cephas we'll put a
link to their EP in the show notes as
well
I am a charm for the phenomenal ever
known I am as quiet and calm as love
being me I gotta have it
do you know too many questions you know
you have to pay with not good
Tommi blood in the night
[Music]
we know
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
gotta have it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you
let's dive into some of these voicemails
Ryan we've got some questions about
budget hang which will be interesting
because did you just say budgeting isn't
that what you prepared for the budgeting
wait wait what episode is this a cool
hwhip dark chocolate boy alright our
first question is from now oh wait so I
wrote down her name phonetically Ilana
our first question from Alana in San
Diego California I noticed that you were
talking about Dave Ramsey in one of your
previous podcast and I just wanted to
know I've listened to him for a while
he's fantastic
brilliant I just wanted to know what
your perspective on credit is so Dave
Ramsey I know it's all about no credit
absolutely not it doesn't help you in
any way don't get a house loan and if
you do even with no credit better than
bad credit but I just kind of wanted to
know what you guys thought about credit
all right Ryan so so Dave Ramsey says
that you that your credit score doesn't
really matter and I can tell you it's
one of the things that was hard for me
to adapt to it first but yeah because
sit here as he has this credit score of
zero right we need to recommend that for
everyone sounds really crazy I I do
recommend it for everyone but I'm a lot
more hardline than you on a lot of stuff
with respect to budgeting well no I'm
not saying that I wouldn't recommend it
I'm just saying recommending it sounds
insane especially because we've been
acculturated this whole this whole
country is ran on credit man you hear
advertisements that say fix your credit
some consumer debt to government debt to
- I guess foreign debt would be the same
thing but I mean this whole country is
where the world runs on credit like are
there any countries out there who were
like net zero I don't know man I'm sure
there was a Middle Eastern country
oh yeah like Saudi Arabia yeah okay yeah
where they have huge huge surpluses
never all intents and purposes like the
world runs on credit yeah yeah but it's
not credit is the problem right it's not
it's not a credit score it's a debt
score right it's they all run on debt
yes yeah and so we use this term credit
like we say credit card or what's your
credit score but maybe if we were just
to flip it around use different
nomenclature and we say what's your debt
score
what's your debt car payment yeah yeah
and so or what's your debt payment for
your car yeah she asked is credit good
or bad and and my answer to you is it's
not necessarily good or bad it's
unnecessary and I'm running into this
recently now I do have a credit score
full disclosure here because I have a
business credit card that is attached to
my name and so but it's something we pay
off every single month and and and
therefore I don't have a zero credit
score I don't have I'm sure my credit
score I don't have no idea what my
credit score is it doesn't matter to me
but here's what I'll say that there are
if I look at it I think no credit score
having a zero credit score it's not even
a zero it's just not having a credit
score right it's it's it's not playing
the game that's probably your best most
ideal scenario having no credit score
whatsoever and I'll talk about why here
in a second but I think beyond that it
it's better to have a good credit score
than to have a bad credit score of
course
so if you were listed in sort of
descending order no credit score is best
if you were if we're going and then
after that it's having a good credit
score is better than the third option
which is having a bad credit score so
yes if you have a bad credit score you
may just want to bypass the trying to
fix it and I'm gonna have a good credit
score no you want no credit score and
that has to do with paying off debt not
having any revolving debts and then and
then working toward working working
toward the a scenario where you never
have to use credit again now zero credit
score though is wouldn't that be
considered a bad credit score though no
no it's not a zero it is
no credit score so having no credit
wouldn't that be wouldn't that be
considered having bad credit like when I
don't know well when I think about like
when we were managing retail stores sure
we did a credit check yes for people who
wanted cellphones exactly someone who
had bad credit versus someone who had no
credit they both came back as a I think
was like a $400 deposit or something
right right but then of course what did
we have for the people who had no credit
score show up whatsoever
we had a review process hmm that's right
and and I'm finding this now with so we
are moving really soon we're not telling
you where it just yet but when I'm out
house hunting right it's it's apartment
hunting really home hunting yeah yeah
yeah I'm finding that you know people
were gonna ask what you they ask about
credit score and everything but it's
much more about can I afford this place
that that's the real question that
they're asking right now there are
people who make $10,000 a year we have
massive amounts of debt and can have a
good credit score because they're
playing the game mm-hmm but if you make
$10,000 a year and you want to rent a
place that is $1,000 a month wait a
minutes how are you gonna afford this
you can and so impartment complex or a
individual who's renting a house to you
or whatever they're not gonna they're
not gonna rent a house to just because
you have a great credit score it's about
having these individual conversations
with with people and so I've been
talking to the homeowner of the place
that I'm looking to rent right now which
we'll talk about on the next episode and
you have to be able to justify can I
afford living in this place to that
person I have to justify to myself first
obviously and and then you have to be
able to say well here's my income and if
you can prove what your income is then
your credit score becomes less relevant
but there are net there's never a time
gonna go into debt right again me
personal right so when someone does look
up your credit because I mean a credit
report is still a very viable thing I
have a credit report because I don't
have no I I don't have no credit score
so when someone looks up your at your
credit and you did
have you had no credit score you self
credit history so they can tell like
okay you're making this amount of income
that you won't have history that's the
thing that this is the thing Dave Ramsey
talks about you won't actually have a
credit report won't come back for you
eventually but it will okay so what a
credit will come back but um but but it
would but it would show basically that
you have no credit like you have no
debts essentially you're not paying off
because that's what a credit report does
it gives you credit score right but it
goes much deeper than that it shows you
all of the it shows all the debts that
one has sure it shows all the late
payment that one has yeah it sure sort
of shows all that stuff so eventually
but if it doesn't come back what that
says to this homeowner is okay Josh
makes X amount of dollars each year and
I know he has no he's not thinning
himself out with all the money that he's
making right now the credit report
itself isn't going to show how much
money I make I have to be able to prove
no no no but what its gonna show is are
you getting in over your head right
because they'll be able to compare that
to what your you know previous year's
tax return is your pay stub or a bank
account by the way they asked for all
these things when when I was applying
for this house that I'm trying to get
into they they asked like okay now I
need to see your last tomb once a bake
statement so okay here they are I need
to see last year's tax return because I
don't have a biweekly paycheck that's it
would they ask for either your last
several pay pay stubs and basically
they're saying I need to be able to
justify renting you this place and the
red flag would be if I had bad credit
not if I had okay credit or I had
because bad credit means I don't pay my
debts right no credit score means you
have debts and you're not paying right
right and and if you look at my report
right now the only thing you'll ever see
there is that one business card that
that I pay off every single month and so
that that's all they'll see my credit
report so my I'm not playing the game so
my score probably isn't you eight
hundred and twenty or whatever the
highest one is but my point is that
doesn't matter I don't have a bad credit
report ideally I'd like to have no
credit report whatsoever and maybe I'll
change that in the future but right now
it doesn't matter
me as long as I don't have anything bad
now I also have identity theft
protection I also have my credit report
frozen so when they went to go run my
credit I had to like call up TransUnion
and unfreeze my credit report we'll put
a link to some resources if you want to
freeze your credit that way if you I
tell you what it Ryan it if you were go
to going to apply for a car loan or
something alright we would have this
when we worked in the corporate world we
ran someone's credit their credit score
would be frozen that means that other
people can't open up accounts in your
name and that's why I have my credit
frozen because I'm never going to run a
credit report unless I'm applying for a
house or a cellphone or something one of
these very rare exceptions when I say
applying for house I mean but to rent a
house and personally I wouldn't I
wouldn't want a mortgage either a in
again I'm I'm not criticizing anyone who
does have a mortgage but you need to be
able to afford the not just the monthly
payment on the mortgage but for me if I
were to ever decide to go that route I
would want to be able to put 50% down I
can't afford that right now put 50% down
on the home and then be able to pay it
off in seven years I want a seven-year
fixed-rate mortgage
I could see doing it in 15 we're one of
only three countries that have two
countries that has a thirty-year
fixed-rate mortgage do you know what
mortgage means what's a it means a death
contract oh that's right it's like it
roots back to death contract oh yeah I
think about that for a second I mean I'm
36 years old if I were to get a 30-year
fixed-rate mortgage right now I'd be 66
I don't I haven't no idea
I loved dr. Christopher Ryan's idea
perfect definitely not recommending this
but it's hilarious
ya know where he talked about so we were
on dr. Christopher Ryan's podcast and he
talked about tangentially speaking yes
great podcast if you've never listened
to it I'll put a link to that show notes
as well but yeah he was like well isn't
like the perfect ideal life is racking
up as much credit as you can like buying
a house at 80 years old because I don't
know how old he is
50 or 55 to 80 55 yeah
and he's like but you know when I'm 60
or 70 he's like don't give me a 30-year
mortgage he's like so the idea is rack
up as much credit as you can and then
die yeah the problem is is then like the
reason why you shouldn't do that a it's
disingenuous it is morally wrong morally
wrong but also that debt would transfer
over to family if there's any like
direct family like there are there are
ways that you could really damage
someone else's credit if doing that but
I thought it was he was obviously he was
joking he was joking yes it was funny
Jen so so I like funny jokes too to just
wrap up this question is is credit good
or bad no well it's unnecessary yeah
well here I'll be I think that why you
and I work so well they gave the white
devils advocate Ryan no it's not about
being in the devil's advocate although I
like to do that a lot but I think that I
kind of like the voice of reason a lot
of times because you are super strict
because I'm so emotional that's just
sick cuz you're not emotional huh so you
can take emotion put that aside and
you're you're very strict with diet
you're very strict with you know your
junk drawer doesn't look like junk like
it's the most organized junk drawer I've
ever seen in my life and you're very
strict when it comes to these rules so
I'm gonna be the voice reason just for a
second yeah what I'll say is actually
the voice of emotion here but go okay
the voice of emotion thank you friend
the the thing is is that I agree with
you 100% like it is unnecessary if you
are making very deliberate decisions if
you are planning ahead you are not it's
like people need a car to go to work but
they don't have to have a twenty
thousand dollar car loan so they can
have a super nice car to ride to work in
right they could go buy at $1,000 or
$2,000 car right and then save up for a
nicer car if that's what they want to do
yes but what I will say is that you know
credit is a good or bad yes it's
unnecessary it is still a tool
it is what it is it's a it's a it's a
tool I hate to use like have you ever
used that jackhammer Emily yeah dude it
sucks I hate using a jackhammer
mm-hmm but sometimes sometimes it's
necessary yeah so I guess all this you
know I'll leave it at that with with my
to sentence it necessary um well I think
it's it's to each their own I mean I
could give you when it would be okay for
me like if I was would it be necessary
okay when I was 18 years old my dad had
like college like the end of the world
was gonna come there's no reason for me
to go to college right so there was no
savings for college he certainly could
not afford to put me through college
right if I wanted to you know be a brain
surgeon I got to go to college for that
right so there are ways to get around it
for free and there are people who have
absolutely done it yeah but there might
be a scenario where it's like okay
taking one of these subsidized loans
what's that scenario if you can't get
your entire tuition covered I know some
people have done it but for to for me to
say that a hundred percent of the people
who want to be brain surgeons could go
through brain surgeon school for free
that's ridiculous yeah and that's absurd
to think that that's all I'm saying and
it's not gonna happen right so that's
what I'm saying if I wanted to be a
brain surgeon and I wanted to put myself
through school and I wasn't able to get
a hundred percent of a covered maybe I'm
able to get fifty percent of a cover
through to you know tuition and grants
and so forth and so on
right um then then I could see myself
taking out like a subsidized loan or
something yeah III wouldn't here's why I
think that when you talk about that a
hundred percent of brain surgeries going
through med school
no of them are going to get loans
there's no question about that
that's just statistics that doesn't mean
that we have to follow the same path
that everyone else follows what I'm
saying is is there a brain surgeon who
made it through all of college and left
debt-free yes unequivocally yes yes oh
you
a recipe so can a hunger gonna follow
the recipe right but and that's my point
is that a hundred percent of the people
who want to be brain surgeons are not
going to be able to follow that rest but
that doesn't matter that that's that's
irrelevant what's relevant is that there
is a recipe that you can follow just
because other people aren't gonna follow
a recipe doesn't mean that you don't
have to there is a recipe out there that
you can follow you don't have to get
into debt it doesn't I can't think of
one scenario I'm open to the idea of
scenarios where you can and and debt it
will be extremely helpful the the one
that stands out that you use sometimes
where you talk about Mark Zuckerberg who
took out a you know 30-year fixed-rate
mortgage on his mansion on his 10
million 20 million dollar mansion
because he has the because that twenty
thirty million dollars whatever it is
you leverage that to make six percent on
average just in indexes index funds yeah
so you can put that money in index fund
but the key for him is he can afford to
do because he's rich enough yeah if you
so if you have the four hundred thousand
dollars it takes to get through med
school and you'd rather invest it
elsewhere and then get the student loans
because you have that money sits sitting
somewhere in some other account that you
know you can pay off yeah I get that if
we're talking about leveraging but I
think the only time you can afford debt
is if you can afford that I guess what
I'm trying to do here is I really don't
want our listeners because every single
one of them not every single one of them
but the majority of them are in debt
right now yeah I am in yeah exactly well
they're not they're all Americans
fifty-three percent of you are Americans
the other forty seven percent are in the
other 192 countries we're not trying to
make you feel bad about having debt what
we're trying to do here is challenge you
to become debt free and to leverage to
are not to leverage debt but to to not
look as debt as leveraging for a better
life yeah but to really look at how not
using this tool what will actually help
you live a more meaningful life um so
that's the only reason why I'm trying to
be the voice of reason here
yeah voice of emotion clearly that's the
thing is you don't want people to feel
bad yeah that's the voice of emotion
right here's what I'll say I do want
people to feel bad if you have debt I
want you to feel bad about it
and here's why not because I don't care
about you no it's because I do care
about you and I want you to get out of
debt because experiencing financial
freedom it opens up so many other
avenues for you in the meantime I want
you to feel some pain I want you to feel
a lot of pain around this debt because I
want you to put a plan together to start
paying off the debt so yeah yeah
absolutely I just thought of another
excuse as to why I would use debt that's
a great word go ahead
what excuse or debt used together I
think it's perfect yeah
if I had a home what percent paid off
yeah my kid got I don't know kidney
cancer yeah I need a kidney transplant
mm-hmm no I don't go into debt just let
him let him go right I would probably
take out a second mortgage but I would
probably take out you know an equity
loan on my home yeah to pay for a kid
surgery yeah so yeah but but you know
what this is an extreme example if
you're on to your point if you really if
one really challenges themselves to not
use credit there are gonna be very very
few excuses to go into debt there's
gonna be extreme they're gonna be
extreme cases and so when you say
extreme let's just change that we're low
but let's say emergencies yeah yeah when
is there ever a time where you're like
shopping at Banana Republic and you have
to buy that that shirt on emergency yeah
if you're putting if you're putting
clothes on a credit card or and you're
going into debt for it or if you're
putting yeah you're absolutely right
like there yes yeah so that is not an
emergency so if you have an emergency
that that makes sense to me but here's
the other thing let's try to mitigate
those emergencies as much as possible
absolutely and most emergencies aren't
don't we write a whole essay on that we
sure did we'll put a link to that one in
the show notes most emergencies are we
treat everything like everything's on
fire all the time I remember we used to
work man like everything was just
constant putting out a fire
it was reactionary and so let's stop
reacting must be a bit more proactive
with with how we're spending our time
our resources our money our attention
and part of that has to do with planning
accordingly
of course you you want to have
catastrophic health insurance for if if
there is some sort of procedure that you
need so you're not going
I mean medical debt is is one of the
reasons that people go bankrupt
we're biggest reasons people go bankrupt
because they they have all this debt
that they've piled up via medical bills
because true emergencies happen and we
need to plan for the emergencies before
they happen because there are such
things as true emergencies and so it
doesn't mean that we have to have the
the the the best Cadillac insurance plan
everything that's covered every single
doctor visit no no my insurance is high
deductible but everything above sixty
six hundred dollars a year for me is is
covered once I pay that deductible now I
have enough money in my emergency fun
emergency fund right that I could pay
that sixty six hundred dollars if I had
to right and I think that's important
and you don't have to be a millionaire
I'm certainly not to have an emergency
fund set aside and so I want to give to
other resources here for Alana we have
an essay if you're in debt right now
anyone listen to this it's called
financial freedom five difficult steps
to get a debt now you know me I hate
listicles and and so it's not it's not
just hey here's five simple steps for
you to get out of debt no this this was
intentionally five difficult steps to
get out of debt this is the the process
that you and I follow tryin to get out
of debt so if you want to see exactly
how Ryan and I got out of debt and it
took four or five years to do it and
I'll tell you later a now man dude my
Corolla 2004 I save that one for Jesse
everyone knows oh yeah yeah I think I
think uh now I'm gonna use here because
I want to use credit to get a new car
okay I really wanted Tesla Model 3 yeah
like 30 thousand bucks right you got put
thousand bucks down I don't think
they're like if you get one right now
you can't you can't even get it till
2018 okay um but my point is is like if
I did that I got the thousand bucks I
said like I've started saving for one
mm-hmm
I got a thousand bucks I could put down
and then I could totally take out a loan
and I could afford that debt payment
every single month right but I'm glad
you're calling debt payment - it's so so
important it's not a car payment so just
to give you an idea where the grow the
curl is that right now the radio does
not work anymore uh-huh AC doesn't work
anymore
right I get new tires on there I mean
like there's so many in my old self when
there is that many problems with a
vehicle because I already had a debt
payment I'm like I might as well just
trade this debt payment in for another
debt payment I'll upgrade my car payment
right like it's gonna cost me two
thousand bucks to fix this stuff I could
just trade this car in to keep my you
know $500 a month car payment going
right and that was my old mentality but
now it's like I will get the AC fixed I
don't know if I get the radio fixed or
not I get a Bluetooth speaker in there
or something right um but my point is is
like I really AM twitching
to like just pull the trigger and like I
go get this car payment but because I
don't want to have a debt payment yeah
because I don't want to I don't want to
I don't want anyone to hold any type of
contract over my head mm-hmm like I am
willing to I want to say sacrifice me I
don't know if it's sacrifice or
compromise yeah compromise but I mean I
kind of in depriving myself from a new
car but I'm ok with that because it is a
net for me it's a net positive to not
take on that debt payment for the new
car you're depriving yourself of
non-essentials yeah and you know what
dude I know I can save this money up in
the next two years yeah like that's my
plan is in the next two maybe two and a
half years I'll have the money saved up
to buy this car what an important word
though plan yeah and I'll tell you the
problem is that most of us we want a
boat we go get we're like oh man yeah I
could get a boat in two and a half years
but I want it now right so I'm gonna get
that debt payment yeah here comes around
and you're like I don't even like this
boat right and I'm still paying for
right exactly exactly so yeah if you
want a plan to get out of debt it's
called financial freedom five difficult
steps to get Odette create a simple
budget plan for the future and regain
control of your finances and the five
steps in there that we just sort of walk
through the first one is budget and and
how you put things in the appropriate
categories second one is pay yourself
talk
investments for the future I also have a
link to my retirement essay in there you
can see all my bank accounts so this
essay is the minimalists comm slash
freedom and then if you want access to
all my retirement accounts you can go to
the minimalists comm slash retirement
there's a whole retirement planning
article their third step in this is
becoming debt free we sort of walk
people through that and how there's no
such thing as good debt I'll say that
again there's no such thing as good debt
unless you're rich enough to afford it
and then it's not even debt right I mean
we think about it it's true if you're
it's in a weird way I was talking to
Beck's about this over the weekend it's
sort of self insurance so remember the
company we used to work for large large
corporation and instead of having law
settlement insurance like a lot of you
know smaller medium-sized firms would
have they had an entire bank account set
aside or divisions set aside they were
self-insured so that if they were sued
someone sued them and they won a $50,000
judgment they didn't have to go to all
state or State Farm or whoever ensures
you have people for these types of
things and said they were self insured
and really what you're talking about
Mark Zuckerberg is self-insuring his
mortgage in a way because he knows he
can pay it off at any time
step four is minimize we talked about
minimalism and and it not being
deprivation but sometimes temporary
deprivation will get you to where you
want to go a little bit faster and the
fifth step in there is about
contribution contributing beyond
ourselves in a meaningful way
you can find that the minimalists com
slash freedom I would love to give a
copy of our book Alana
she said in her voicemail Ryan she said
she was an auditory learner so we it
just came out an audiobook six and a
half hours it's called essential there's
twelve different chapters in in this
book essential it's available as a book
or an e-book but well it's also an
audible so Sean if you have any audible
download codes maybe you could send her
a six and a half hour audio book because
one of the chapters in that book is
about finances and budgeting and I think
Alanna you will find a lot of value in
in that chapter is that our longest
audio book it is definitely our longest
yeah so our shortest is minimalism
ironically very
/ vo-- yeah yeah so that one's like two
and a half hours and it's our shortest
book and it's out in Australia now by
the way minimalism live a meaningful
life and the mid-tier it's actually it's
pretty closed over five hours everything
that remains which is my favorite book
of everything that we have written our
next question is from Jesse Jesse in
Italy Jenks and my partner of five years
ended up moving in on with his parents
that I had a question in regards to
moving in with relatives or moving in
with friends or roommates to possible to
minimize living expenses and to maximize
I'm used to open up finances to do
things like pay off debt and to also
being able to save in you know plan for
whatever passions we want to pursue in
the future another question I had was
regarding in terms of paying off debt
what debt should be paid off of one
order an example is we have a hard note
in the car something that we read I'm in
order to work
so should we focus on paying on things
like car loans car note and student debt
or things like a parking ticket
something I've gotten out of hand and
other forms of debt that have just kind
of collected along the way from being in
a place we couldn't really afford
basically the expensive all right voice
of emotion uh-huh it's gonna be my new
nickname
what do you know Jesse wants to know
about paying off his parking ticket
should I pay off my car first Oh Jesse
first I wish so thankfully we're
building this new podcast studio Ryan
because what I'd like to do right now is
call Jesse and there are a few questions
I would ask him the first one I would
ask him about his individual debts but
but actually even before that I would
ask him how old are you and because he
has a lot of issues that a lot of young
people have people in their early 20s in
there they're contemplating should I
move
back in with my relatives I'm moving in
with a partner do we move into grandma's
basement and what do you say to that
because I think my voice of reason will
be different from what you're saying I
think that you know living with a mom
isn't embarrassing if you're actually
working towards something yeah yeah I
can do a saying no or or is it is it
wrong like dude if I had the option you
know of moving in with a relative to pay
off a lot of debt yes like if I could
get rid of if I could sell I'm just you
know putting myself in a scenario here I
have a house I got a you know $1,200
mortgage or delicious called a thousand
dollar mortgage for simplicity sake if I
could sell that house move in with my
grandma save $1,000 a month right and
pay her like $200 a month right or even
find an apartment that was like $400 a
month I mean there are other things you
can do besides moving in with Grandma
but if that's gonna if that's gonna make
if that's gonna give me the most
leverage with my with my dollars right
then like there's I don't think there's
any shame in it man yeah what's what's
when I see you know like what is it like
your stereotypical guy who lives in his
mom's basement that he's 33 years old
right his couch is made out of pizza
boxes and like there is no plan to move
out and they're just simply kind of
skating by working part-time at you know
whatever insert crazy part-time job
there yeah
there are part-time model here's the
thing right I I agree there shouldn't be
any shame in this but you used a word
there that I will reiterate what's your
plan yeah you said yeah I said plan
so so the other question I would ask
Jessie here is how long and again once
we have this this new podcasting studio
we will start taking live callers on the
air he was asking how long he is no no
no I'm saying I'm saying how long how
long are you gonna be there if you're
moving in with I don't know who the
relative is but let's say it's grandma's
basement yeah with your partner first
off that's gonna put a strain on your
relationship so yeah so you're you're
giving up one cost which is your your
misstatement it's a sharing of multiple
relationships cuz its relationship with
his partner
yeah but it's also relationship with
this partner's parents yeah and their
relationship with their partner so there
there are there are a lot of different
relationships being affected and
strained yeah so we're saying partners
parents not grandma's couch or okay so
partners parent if you're moving in with
your partner's parent that's what he
said his parents are partners parents I
think okay okay and so if you're moving
them with them yeah you're putting
strain on both so that's an additional
call so you might be saving the six
hundred bucks a month and rent or
whatever your rent was before or you can
move to a small studio apartment with
your partner and and find you know find
something that's 300-400 bucks a month
you you depending on your in Illinois
yeah you can find something relatively
inexpensive as long as you're not in
Chicago if you're in downstate Illinois
you can you can find you can find a
place which is very reasonable yeah
absolutely Midwest
yeah yeah except for Chicago yeah and
maybe a few other few other places yeah
like 90 percent of the Midwest for sure
and so my point is there are some other
costs that are going to be associated
with moving in with your in-laws yeah
we're moving with your in-laws or your
partner's parents and so yeah like if
you're moving in it's so someone asks
you Jesse what why did you move in with
your partner's parents and you answer
back so we could save money
mm-hmm like that's kind of an incomplete
answer yeah it's like what are you
saving the money for yeah
oh we're saving money because we plan to
be debt-free in the next five years
right like that is a much better much
direct answer and that's going to late
like if someone told me that like that
would make sense to me
oh yeah like okay you're living with
your relatives or your parents so you
can pay for debt in the next five years
that's a great plan yeah I personally I
wouldn't I would never do it I would
never do it longer than six months
personally Josh he wouldn't live with
anyone longer than six Wow I mean
besides backs yeah yeah hello but I'm
saying and and so and even that's
difficult for me I mean here's the thing
I would yeah I would never do a period I
would never move in but but here's
here's why I would find a way to better
use that because here's the thing it's
not free you move in with the inlaws
it's not free you still you
better not be free for you you better be
doing something around the couch you can
you better contribute now how are you
gonna use I could use that time
differently to to earn a different
income to to develop some sort of side
hustle to to you know drive for uber or
lyft or whatever to deliver pizzas which
I've done in the past to pay off my
debts instead of moving in because I
know what that would do to me it would
strain my relationship with my partner
and so the question you really need to
ask yourself maybe it's gonna be great
maybe you move in there for six months
to a year you have a plan in place you
you go back to that essay I just
recommended to Ilana the financial
freedom essay and you really start to
pay off these debts and so you can
afford a small little studio apartment
with you and your partner so you're not
a strain on them and you have a plan to
be out of there so it might be January 1
swings around I'm going to be out of
here by January 1 that's what I'm
committing to you the in-laws
this is gonna be give me enough time to
pay off my debts now now Ryan he
mentioned he has this well the question
he asks is what what or do you pay off
debts in well that one's easy that's
just the debt snowball that Dave Ramsey
toxic yeah I mean that is yeah Josh and
I are obviously going to recommend that
so you start off with the little debts
first and then you work your way up to
the big debts yeah and I was when I was
listening to his question I was thinking
about you know asking Jessie like if you
were to climb a mountain do you want to
climb the steepest part first oh by the
way on this hypothetical mountain uh-huh
the part of the mountain that's above
the steepest part is just getting
steeper and steeper yeah as you're
climbing this beginning ascent so
looking at and some people do want to
take the hardest things on first but
they're making everything else work
because everything is accruing interest
yeah so you're just making the the large
or the smaller amounts if you're if
you're if you're tackling the larger
amount of debt first your smaller
amounts probably have the bigger
interest rate on it quite often they do
and the thing that Dave Ramsey to talk
about is it doesn't really matter what
you're trying to do is build
and if you have 16 different debts a lot
of them are gonna be really tiny ones
you get those tiny victories up front
where I'm gonna pay off this $37 credit
card and I've got another credit card
that is $119 and you feel like you're
gaining momentum and it allows you to
better tackle the the the other debts
that are in front of me dude if you
don't pay your parking tickets and you
get busted they're gonna take away your
license so it doesn't matter if you have
a car or not yeah so yeah dude pay off
your parking you've got to pay your
parking tickets but here's the other
thing that's gonna be hard to hear Jesse
but you gotta get rid of car man you got
to get rid of that car and and buy
something that does not have a car
payment but I can't afford it
yes you can I know you said you like the
help my commute is an hour each way and
I gotta have a fifty thousand dollar
luxury car duh right
enjoy that commute right well guess what
Ryan is debt-free and he has a 2004
Toyota Corolla with 300,000 miles on and
leakes radios broken a/c doesn't work
right now
you'd be lucky to get a thousand bucks
for that car right now oh my god and so
here's the thing someone will buy that
coffee
my point is Jesse by the equivalent by
the beater by the junker car until you
get out of debt you got a hat and you
can upgrade eventually and you can go
from one junker to a slightly less junky
junker but right now and here's the
thing you're probably not gonna do it
man because it's difficult and it's
gonna create some pain and some tension
but the truth is I mean how backwards is
this you're gonna move in with the
in-laws and you have a car payment come
on man but that doesn't add up there's
this I saw I used to listen to
I still do listen to him bear bear area
hip-hop artist efore T and he's he talks
about all these guys out here they have
$80,000 cars but they don't even own
their house right and it's sort of the
same thing man but on a smaller scale
obviously man if you can't even pay your
own rent but you have a car payment
you're hustling backwards man yeah you
gotta let go and then voice of emotion
here agrees with you I wanna [ __ ] I want
to shake Jesse dude that wall cuz I'll
tell you that was
people always ask me like well how did
you leave your job and just become a
minimalist and it's like well it's not
really hard like it wasn't a minimalist
till I said so and it was well before I
I got laid off and even quit my job yeah
you were a minimalist you're saying you
know and you're paying off your debts a
long time before ever leaving the
corporate world yeah and what in the
first debt that I tackled was my car
yeah you know I don't know how much I
owed on it but I know that I found
someone to pay I think I ended up
spending $300 to get rid of the car
you're upside down a little bit yeah I
was upside down just a tiny bit even if
you're upside down a lot you still have
to get rid of it Jeff but then I got
that Corolla
yeah and had no payment on it and dude
that was one of the best feelings ever
so Jesse if you do this like I'm sure
you got a thousand bucks saved up if not
then save a thousand bucks but find a
junker to buy and if you and maybe the
car you have now you can maybe you're
not upside down on it maybe get a little
bit more for it and help you know pay
for a car that doesn't have a debt
payment that's attached to it and dude
if the roof leaks it's okay if it
doesn't have AC you're in Illinois it's
probably okay it's okay
I had college dude I would not recommend
someone who lived in like Dallas Texas
to have a car without AC like that's
right that would be miserable but but I
mean but I mean I think the listeners
are getting my point here yeah is that
in order to in order to become debt-free
in order to meet your financial goals no
matter who you are you were going to
have to make some sacrifices
yes and you're you might even have to
deprive yourself a little bit at first
mmm and some temporary deprivation now
you know Josh and I always talk about
how minimalism is not deprivation but
sometimes you got to do that temporarily
yeah you got a you know don't eat out
with your friends eat as many meals as
you can at home you know don't go see
movies once a week go once every other
month there are some things that you
might have to deprive yourself with and
Jesse for you it sounds like depriving
yourself of I don't know what kind of
car you have dude but I'm sure if you
have a payment on it it's a nicer car
but you're gonna have to deprive
yourself of a nicer car for a little bit
before you get your debt paid off
there's a quote from Dave Ramsey by the
way Jessie we I bought this book by the
case we'll send you a copy of Dave
Ramsey's book it's called Total Money
Makeover and it helped me get out of
debt as well he talks about snowball in
there and developing your budget but
there's a quote that he often says and
I'm gonna butcher it but he says you
live like nobody else today so you can
live like nobody else tomorrow yeah and
that's that's what Ryan's talking about
this temporary deprivation lay yeah
you're gonna have to tighten the belt a
bit and you have to live like like the
other people around you aren't living
because you're being more frugal than
you'd like to be and you're being more
strict and you you're stretching every
dollar but tomorrow you'll be able
tomorrow metaphorically you'll be able
to live like no one else because you'll
be debt-free and you'll be free because
of it alright our next question who's
the next question from Ryan it is from
Tara in Virginia I have recently been
applying minimalism to my finances I've
actually created an excel an excel sheet
which I thoroughly enjoyed nerding out
too as I fill it out I however do not
realize how much money I was spending
unconsciously on eating out and random
other items that do not add value to my
life anyway
I'm wondering if you have any words of
wisdom to encourage patience with myself
and or how to speed along the process of
developing and adhering through a
realistic value-based budget so you know
I got excited when I heard the word
Excel spreadsheet Ryan know I've stopped
using X I'm so proud of her because I
cannot dude my um I'll say a relative
I'm not gonna call out the specific
relative yeah but they were visiting
within the last year and they were like
I don't know what to do like I need a
car and I gotta do this blow I mean you
know they're just laying out all their
financial woes and I'm like do you have
a budget and they're like no I'm like
okay I was like I'm not going to coach
you anymore until you come back to me
with a budget they still have not put a
budget together there are so many people
out there who know they need a budget
have not spent the time to do it
that is if you can't take the first
then you're never gonna become debt free
yep so Tara just congratulations on
putting the Excel spreadsheet together
that is an awesome first step and it's a
hard one because it makes you it makes
you look in the mirror and it makes you
be honest with yourself
oh it's scrutinizing too like so in a
weird way I'm budgeting right now with
my diet
so it talked about doing the the
ketogenic diet early on at the beginning
of this episode and the app I'm using my
Fitness Pal it I budgets my calories
yeah so my daily objective is 2300
calories but I want to get over 70% of
that from fat and so I find I find that
like I'm budgeting in a different way
and it makes you scrutinize like oh my
god I did not know that a tablespoon of
balsamic vinegar had yet one carbonate
or whatever and so like I just I'm sorry
I'm just having visions of me taking on
this diet and freaking out of it about a
tablespoon of balsamic vinegar oh yeah
you're you're toast I'm sorry I'm sorry
and not mean like bacon so I'm eating
bacon now right but bacon is cured with
brown sugar so I can't even really do
much begging you think of bacon is a
nice fatty thing that's gonna help your
fat it does but bacon is always cured
with brown sugar that's how you make
bacon now Josh did you know that if you
say beer can in an Australian accent it
sounds like bacon in a Jamaican accent
prove it we don't have time keep going
alright alright anyway so I'm budgeting
in my whole point is that once you start
scrutinizing it down to the dollar level
or the calorie level or the
micronutrient level it it opens up this
whole world of you know there's this old
saying oh you can't you can't manage
what you don't measure and I don't know
that's always true but I think that it's
it is so true for diet and especially
for budgeting your dollars knowing where
every dollar is going throughout the
month now an Excel spreadsheet might be
might be ideal for for Tara but there's
a really good app out there and it's
free by the way it's called every dollar
oh yeah that's Dave Ramsey yeah
yeah and so I used the paper version of
it a very long time ago and that helped
me the whole envelope system that he
uses helped me but every dollar it's a
free app and I think that it may be the
Excel spreadsheet works great for you
and however you want to do it whatever
tool works best for you but take a look
at the different tools see if see if
that one might might help out now Ryan
she said how to help her with her with
patience well she didn't realize how
much money she was spending now I would
use the word non-essentials hmm so how
do you get down to that how do you
figure out what's essential and
non-essential yeah so so you and I did
something called the neat needwant like
list but if I were to rename that today
because we did this a few years ago the
needwant like list we really identified
the things that you surely need the
things that you wanted that added value
to your life and the things that you
just sort of like like yeah I like the
satellite radio or whatever so how would
you rename it essential non-essential
and junk and yes you know I like that
essential essential we should go back
and edit that essay or we can just we
can write another one eventually I've
been writing bunch on the website by the
way you can subscribe to all the the
essays for free over at the minimalists
comm via email I love that dude
essential non-essential and junk is
that's essentially what it is man like
yeah was that was that a pun it was upon
it is essential yeah and and so we were
we were helping someone recently
declutter their home we were doing it
for a reporter on BuzzFeed this BuzzFeed
video video that we did we were out in
Los Angeles when we were out on tour and
helped her put things in the three piles
and now here's the thing we justify
everything this is essential absolutely
needed but the truth is we need far
fewer things and we think and so if I
were to look at my essentials my non
essentials and my junk most of the
things that I owned when I was 27 years
old and I was simplifying my life for
the first time the vast majority 90 plus
percent was junk it wasn't actually
adding real value to my life there was
some weird perceived value or I was
holding on to it just in case and in
most cases but I had to slash that and
so a hundred percent of your junk has to
go now that's not just junk that you
have at home
it's the new junk that we bring into our
lives and what I mean by that it's not
actually adding value to your life it
could be eating out at Chuck E Cheese
because that's where I go and I want to
eat out did they have a gluten-free menu
I don't know have a menu other
chuck-e-cheeses in the Pacific Northwest
I just want to say your childhood wasn't
lit unless you spend some time at
chuck-e-cheeses don't ever use that word
around me again what chucky cheese yeah
most of the stuff that we spend money on
his junk meaning it's not adding real
value to our life but then there are
some things that are non essentials but
it's not junk it non-essential means it
adds value to our life but it's not
absolutely necessary and I found a way
when I was first budgeting this sounds
crazy I found a way to cut a hundred
percent that's the temporary deprivation
a hundred percent of those non
essentials they'll give us some examples
let's see here so so so a lot of the
bills that I was spending money on home
internet cable TV anything I was
spending money at run regularly music
things that that weren't absolutely
essential to god life going out to e
yeah most of the going out to you was
junk but it was for them because because
the the need was eating right right and
so maybe going out to eat with friends
yes then I did get some value from it or
yeah I got some value because I didn't
have to prep everything but I did start
making meals at home because eating is
essential so let's just talk about
essentials real quick the essentials are
things like having a roof over your head
having clothes on well I already owned
enough clothes I didn't have to buy any
new clothes I can go shopping in my own
closet and be completely contented by
that experience but I found a way to cut
down my essentials by 50 percent I moved
into a smaller apartment I reduced my
electricity and use the air conditioning
less frequently I mean there were things
where I'm like I'm going to really
squeeze every dollar that I have
here and I even reduce my essentials by
30% now maybe maybe Tara you can't you
can't reduce your essentials by 50% but
maybe you can reduce it by 20% and you
can get rid of all of the non-essentials
right now temporarily here's the cool
thing about that though
once you become debt-free you start
bringing those non essentials they still
add value to your life these are things
that truly add value to life when you
start bringing them back in it feels so
much better because you know you're
bringing it back in deliberately and you
feel so much less guilty man yeah like
that's the other thing too it's like I
was there when I was you know deep in
debt but I'm gonna go out with a friend
and have a meal and I'd put it on my
credit card right and it was a good
experience with my friend and I did get
value out of it but like I would feel
guilty like I Here I am just putting
more debt on to this debt card yeah and
now the other thing that I realized when
I started bringing some of those things
back in in my life like I started buying
music again and and and buying books and
instead of going to the library and I
found that many of the things I thought
were non essentials we're actually junk
and I said oh yeah this adds value to my
life no no no it's actually junk and so
you don't bring any of the junk back
into your life so slash slash slash you
can find that essay it's the minimalists
comm slash want we'll put a link to that
in the show notes as well one last
question she had how do i how do I speed
up the process well I think he just
answered that right because I guarantee
right now yeah so yeah I was gonna say
it like if I if she was to lay out her
expenditures I guarantee you and I could
find an extra 10 an extra 20 bucks a
month maybe an extra 100 or $200 a month
right but there I mean if she truly want
to speed up the process get clear on
what the essential stuff is the
non-essential stuff is and give it and
give up as much as you can to pry
temporarily deprive yourself yeah I mean
dude eating peanut butter and jelly and
ramen noodles is a horrible diet but
yeah you can do the healthy equivalent
to that there is a healthy above
actually we should actually start coming
up with a healthy equivalent we should
get backs to do that at minimal wellness
she's the dietician yeah so what's the
cheapest healthiest way to eat because
that's one thing I hear a lot too well
it's too expensive to eat healthy nah
that's a total bullshitting by the way
it's too expensive to not eat hell yeah
you know what it's too expensive if I go
down to the Fresh Market right here in
Missoula and eat organic through it's
way too expensive I never buy like I go
to the farmers market right or I'll go
to other places where I know that they
have affordable organic stuff well what
I'm saying is too expensive to not eat
healthfully what I mean is it's gonna
cost you in the long run oh yeah oh yeah
it's good
yes and so here's here's what I'll say
she said how do I speed up the process
and how do I be patient I don't want you
to be patient I want you to be upset
about this I want you to feel the pain
be impatient about your debt that's what
I wrote down here be impatient with that
don't accept debt don't have patience
with your debt be so impatient that you
know you must make some sort of shittim
added that they're dead yeah I
definitely don't want you to be patient
and in fact I want you to be so
impatient that you so the equation here
is simple Ryan you have to make more
money than you spend if you want to pay
off your debt well how do you do that
well first off you spend less you give
the best way to give yourself a pay
raise is to spend less money if you want
a dramatic pay raise spend dramatically
less money but on top of that once
you've done that you figure out how to
make more money now for me we didn't
have Eber and lift back in the day so I
delivered pizzas and I felt like an
idiot I was working in the corporate
world delivering pizzas but I was I'm
gonna make some more money somehow and
make a few hundred bucks more a week I'm
gonna how am I gonna allocate my time so
I can earn more income in the short term
it's not a long term plan but what is
your side hustle and and maybe that's
driving with lifts and and any extra
time you have you got an hour five hours
a week yeah like it's gonna that's an
extra hundred bucks a week yeah and so
instead of pacifying yourself find ways
to schedule in that side hustle that you
can make some short-term money to pay
off those debts yeah so I would like to
rephrase her question about being
patient I think what she's asking is is
how can she stay more focused and what
I'll say is focus on your daily tasks
like don't look at
what you're gonna be spending next week
or the week after like you if you have
your budget and after listening to this
podcast I'm assuming you have slashed
even more of your expenses stay focused
on what you need to do daily and then
also do focus on that end result focus
on being debt-free you have a light at
the end of the tunnel do you know how
many people don't even have that light
to look forward to so if you can a just
take your daily tasks your daily maybe
your daily focus is a better way of
looking I hate the word task yeah but
you know taking on a day-to-day basis
one step at a time one action at a time
and then stay focused on that end result
that is what is going to give you some
some some better focus and help you stay
motivated to get to that that light at
the end of the tunnel zero if you want
to see how Ryan and I stayed focused
throughout our journey and we went from
the suit-and-tie corporate guys with a
lot of debt to becoming debt free
minimalists we're gonna send you a copy
of our book everything that remains so a
story of five year journey of our lives
that that transition that transformation
and regaining focus I think you'll
especially find value in chapter 8 where
you sort of see that it's almost like
the before and after there's two parts
in the book in Chapter eight is the
beginning of the the second part of the
book so Sean if you could reach out to
her send her the book version the eBook
version or it's now on audible as well
as a five and a half hour audio book if
we have an audible download code you can
send that over to her I would appreciate
it alright we'd love to hear what you
all have to say so we have a comment or
tip about budgeting for anyone who
called in today then leave us a
voicemail for zero six two one nine
seven eight three nine you can also
leave a voice memo you can send one
right from your phone to podcast at the
minimalists comm we will air our
favorite comments and tips on a future
episode alright let's move on to our
hashtag ask the minimalist lightning
round where we answer questions from
social media we are on twitter and
instagram and facebook at the
minimalists during this lightning round
this is where Ryan and I do our best to
answer each question which is a short
shareable less than 140 character
response we also put the text to these
minimal Maxim's in the show notes so you
can copy
paste our pithy answers on social media
if you like you can also find all of our
minimal Maxim's in the show notes and
now at minimal Maxim's com we'd to set
that up and Jess our social media
manager Jess Williams who was an
all-around outstanding human being she
is it was her idea wasn't it yeah it was
she's curating all of our our pithy
answers and putting them in one place so
you could find them over there at
minimal Maxim's com
isn't it great to have awesome people in
your life that can come up with great
ideas and help out all right I'm just no
[Laughter]
rhetorical question I got it wrong I'm
just gonna move on to the ask the
minimalist lighting around here our
first question is from Delaney how do
you stick to your budget without
limiting yourself so far that you miss
out on parts of life with friends and
family all right let me let me dig out
my my pithy answer here it is no matter
what we always miss out on something so
it's important to replace the fear of
missing out with the joy of missing out
so Truman you know how many things were
missing out on right now Josh right when
everything when's the last time you went
apartment-hunting on Craigslist in
Jackson Mississippi that's what I was
doing earlier actually when you're
asking me what I was doing on my
computer because I did I was I was so
worried about missing out on the great
deals yes and yes I like Jackson it's a
good town we've been there on tour
before love listen but here's the thing
you're always missing out then we have
the best tacos in Jackson if you ever
been the Jackson and the tacos you're
missing out there were some great great
the best tacos on an entire hundred city
tour was in Jackson Mississippi anyway
you're always missing out and the key is
let's let's replace that that that fear
of missing out with the joy of missing
out I love that yeah because like it's
it's like the joy of letting go of
opportunities like I don't know
we turn down stuff all the time really
good opportunities yeah and we miss out
boy happy - yeah but it feels really
good say no to something so we can say
yes to what we're focused on that is a
nice pithy answer but I think you have
another one here my pet the answer is
this sacrifices are necessary in order
to meet one's financial goals and then I
got a little parenthetical here and
thank goodness sacrificing virgins is a
way of the past hey man that's
triggering me there's there's some
cultures it's still sacrifice virgins
Ryan and you're not you you're not
thinking about their color really then
what's really hidden cult or something
yeah man is there a country where that's
still legal it's in Mississippi our next
question is from Katie what are your
recommendations for those of us in the
pre budget stage free budgets and quotes
yeah I just look just coined a new term
the pre budget stage I'm not ready to
make every dollar go in its place but
I'm getting there all right well here's
my short answer my minimal maximum for
you Katie win would now be a good time
to have a budget I think you're gonna
flip that around Ryan you could say when
would now be a bad time to have a budget
and I mean it's uh it's obviously a
little a bit of a truism there you know
now is always the best time to have a
budget right and so you can't go back
and say I wish I would have had a budget
a year ago yeah you can worry about that
and beat yourself up over it but now it
was the best time to have a budget so
hopefully some of the tips we gave you
and you hop on every dollar or wherever
your Excel spreadsheet would be now is
the time to have a budget Katie we say
this in our tour stuff now is the time
for less but now is the time for a
budget so when would now be a good time
for budget or when would now be a bad
time to have a budget Ryan can you think
of at I was like I really shouldn't have
a budget right now this
terrible yeah when I really wanted to go
have that expensive meal of my friends
right so then it was actually good or
just felt bad in the pot gotcha
oh that's actually pretty good man cuz
it is it is at a femoral the instant
gratification yeah that we will we will
take that to forsake the long term the
long term what word am I looking for
long term benefits us from from sticking
to a budget yeah so yeah Katie um keep
on living in an ephemeral life and you
will constantly live in ephemerality
yeah I've got so I've gotta fall it's
not my pity answer though know that that
is called a tautology where this thing
means the same thing that you're saying
anyway I'm a four year old Ella and she
lives like that where like it's always I
need to make what all this chocolates
making me want to eat more chocolate
right that's sort of the thing like
she's not budgeting out the chocolate I
have to budget it out for her but guess
what it's because she's four years old
right and so so Katie stop acting like a
four-year-old no this is me caring about
Katie I care about her I want her to
make some changes but in order to do
that you got to have a budget yeah I
care about you and that's why I'm doing
this for you
this is gonna hurt me more than a hate
telling people that they're acting like
a four-year-old yeah that doesn't bring
me pleasure at all I'm not some sort of
sadist you're smiling right now judge no
I'm not you're always smiling so that
doesn't really count that's true all
right
oh my pet the answer is waiting around
for one day it will always keep you
waiting one day or day one you decide
yes indeed all right our next question
is from juice in de the cold hard truth
is that I am going to be haunted by
student loans
by now how does one still have a life
man that that question like it hurt my
heart when I heard her say that you know
that the cold truth is I'm gonna have
student loans until I die and my first
my first reaction was like you got to
change your truth yes cuz with that
attitude yeah you're right like it's
gonna be a horrible life you're planning
for failure right now the cold hard
truth is I'm going to continue to fail
the cold hard truth is I'm not going to
be free and so what my short answer is
my short answer is is change your
beliefs change your life amen
I think if she's got a do man she's got
a book she's gonna instead of saying the
cold hard truth is that I'm gonna be
haunted by student loans till I die
maybe you need to radically change I
believe to the cold hard truth is I am
going to get out of debt just send a
Google how I got out of $100,000 worth a
student debt I mean there's a recipe out
there there are so many recipes who
people who 200,000 but I mean 300,000
whatever it is like figure out someone
else's recipe and you know maybe you
can't follow it exactly but there are
certainly going to be ingredients so I
think this plays into my my epiphany
answer here which is get a plan in place
or be lost forever I think that's the
perfect answer I know you've got some
other stuff to add to that but like to
me that's perfectly pithy like without a
vision people perish is sort of the old
the old biblical passage yeah but but
yeah if you don't have if you don't have
a plan if she just didn't have a vision
her vision is um I'm giving up yeah
that's not a vision and if you throw
your hands in the air well then like I
have I know people friends family who
they've done that and they've acquiesced
to constantly running from debt
collectors stressed out yeah and like
they're living stress out and they are
giving up the short-term pain of coming
up with a plan and acting on it for that
ephemerality of well if I can move to a
different state or if I can change my
phone number or if I just stop answering
my phone then I can avoid you know
people haunted me for debt well
they're gonna try and you know track
that person down for the rest of their
life they want that they want their
money I remember watching remember the
Roseanne show oh yeah
just Roseanne I hear they're bringing it
back anyway keep going you know you and
I grew up really poor and like we would
try my mom some months was trying to
decide do I pay the electric bill
and by the way the answer is yes you pay
the electric bill before you pay the
house bill but some less you would
alternate and so like we'd have past due
notices eventually electric would get
shut off and you know sometimes we'd get
eviction notices on the door and it was
I didn't so how stressful it was to her
and I vowed that when I turned 18 I
would never let that happen to me and by
any means necessary
and part of the has to do with making
good decisions with my resources not
becoming an alcoholic and and aligning
my behaviors with the person I want it
to be I just pulled this out of the
trash can Ryan while you were talking
this is looks like it's a pink slip it
looks like an eviction notice right I
got this in the mail and I can remember
growing up this would have been this
would have been devastating because it
would have been true so this is says
dear YMCA member this is a friend of a
friend
friendly reminder by the way you don't
put a friendly friendly reminder on a
big pink past-due notice this is a
friendly reminder that there are past
due fees on your account please contact
the greater Missoula Family YMCA to
bring your account current by the last
day of this month and so like they're
there it's very passive-aggressive thank
you for being part of our community and
here's the thing like I had got a new
debit card with my the chip updated in
it right and so like I forgot to update
it with the YMCA so I I took care of it
yesterday actually I went in there
yesterday and this this would have
stressed me out because it was like Oh
which bill do I have to force it even
when I was making really good money in
the corporate world I would sometimes
have past-due I would mess my credit
report up and everything else and that
was stressed me out but my point is that
there was so much stress around my
budget because I didn't have a freaking
budget
you gotta have a budget and you gotta
have more empowering beliefs because
your belief that you're gonna be haunted
for the rest of your life like you said
earlier right yeah with that attitude
you will so you know I can tell that
Justin is scared like she has fear and
coming up with a plan is it's difficult
because of that fear of failure so I had
a little bit of room left and my tweet
here so the second part of it is so it's
you know the first part is get a plan in
place or be lost forever also be
prepared to learn along the way if your
plan fails readjust but never give up
yeah so you know we're up on the plan
but don't give up on where you're going
yeah and just into whether it's a plan
to get out of debt or whether it's a
plan to avoid debt I hate to tell you
but you're probably gonna fail in life
before you die we all are yeah and it's
not a matter of avoiding failure as much
as it is learning from when we when our
plan does fall apart or if it starts to
fall apart it's it's readjusting and
learning from where it's not working and
pulling it back together learning from
failure I'm like cringing as I say that
I feel like that is such a overused stop
snapping into the microphone if so if
anyone out there needs to be shaking a
little bit more I don't have time to
read this right now but there is an
essay on our website called eleven signs
you might be broke and here's the thing
we're all broke or broken at some point
in our lives and that essay it's just
the minimalists calm slash broke we'll
put a link to it in the show notes as
well some of the the key indicators that
you might be broke one your living
paycheck-to-paycheck number two you have
credit card debt number three you have
student loan debt number four you have a
monthly car payment so if you have any
of these things you're broke you are
broke and I outline Ryan and I outline
exactly what that means for you and in
that essay so you can see all 11 signs
that you might be broke and in that
essay all right Ryan let's move on to
our added value
Porsche in the show where we talk about
something that has added value to our
lives
recently for me Ryan I saw a movie while
I was I was out in Los Angeles last week
and I had some downtime and there was
this movie I've been meaning to see it's
called Columbus now you and I grew up
Dayton Ohio
do you know two hours from Dayton Ohio
is a town called Columbus yes not
Columbus Ohio though Columbus Indiana Oh
interesting it is it's say just south of
Indianapolis
it is like the mid-century architecture
mecca of the Midwest of the United
States the architecture in this film was
I want to say it was like one of the
main characters of the film but it was
so well done it was like this romance
story that wasn't a romance story and it
had to do with moving on like from as
your the the two main characters are in
their early 20s and one of us a little
bit older than the other and one is sort
of his father is is dying or might be
dying we're not really sure and then the
the other character she her her mom has
some sort of addiction and she's in a
weird way taking care of her mom and she
has to let go of that so as you can sort
of pursue her own life and the film was
just fantastic but part of the reason it
was fantastic was the lighting and the
atmospherics and the architecture in
this and it what I'm hearing you say is
how boring this movie is it's so good to
believe it was well written it was well
written but but there was something
about the Josh is there nudity or
violence in this only if you're in the
theater
[Laughter]
I'm sorry continue with your added value
ryan just gets naked starts beating me
up man it was such a good film now
here's the thing it's I hate doing this
because it's a fairly limited release I
don't know that it's available where you
are so hopefully it'll be out on iTunes
or somewhere soon but man
it's the best movie I've seen so far
this year it's called Columbus oh yeah
Ryan what about you dude I have more
records than you today yes I'm sorry not
Rec OHS added value yes indeed things
that are adding value to my life yeah um
well you've mentioned that movie made me
think of get out I finally saw I know
you already recommended that like a
while ago but dude that movie was so
you're right to you like on the edge of
your seat the whole time I feel like
most of us who are consumers we're in
the sunken place right like when we in
that consumer mindset like that's where
you are you're just sort of like sitting
there like spaced out in the sunken
place anyway I don't want to give in
there no spoilers because you can easily
ruin that film yeah by you all I'll say
is led like it's from so many different
angles it's really good yeah others
leave it at that
um okay the two things that have been
adding value in my life I want to be
very clear these are not recommendations
because I'm just talking about a couple
supplements I've been taking one of them
Jeff Sarris with Spira media he for
those of you who don't know who Jeff
Services you probably have heard of
Spira media they're the ones that pretty
much make Josh and i's website look
beautiful yeah um he recommended this I
think it's pronounced the nine th EA and
I and II I don't know anyway the inane
theanine maybe that's what it is
sounds right um so he was basically
giving me some like intermittent fasting
tips how to you know get some more
energy without drinking more coffee
because I usually like typically what
I'll do is have a coffee when I wake up
yeah if I'm recording a podcast I
usually will have just only one coffee
but like at home but I'll stop on the
way to get a coffee or I will go into
the break room here and if they have
coffee in there like I will get a cup of
that coffee
Shawn was getting coffee earlier today
and I'd like the placebo in me was like
was that C was probably not the right
word but anyway I got this impulse to be
like oh yeah coffee
sounds good but then I was like wait a
minute I do not need coffee right now
right and and it's because of I think
for me it's because of the Thea 9 we're
going with that theanine theanine we're
going with that pronunciation and then
I've also been taking dynein
pronunciation I will hop over this table
and kick your ass
live on our body warning contains
violence I got this recommended from
just a doctor down in Hamilton he was he
was telling me the musical no in
Hamilton Montana oh he's got a he's got
like a practice there and then he also I
think he has one on Spokane - his name
is dr. Matt select and I don't think he
really has anything online but but a
awesome guy but he was telling me about
how the majority people the vast
majority people have a magnesium
deficiency right and how that
contributes to a lot of you know
afternoon drag and energy levels
essentially mm-hmm so he just
recommended he's like dude if you're not
doing you know float tanks and getting
the magnesium through the through the
epson salt there or you're not doing
epson salt baths mm-hmm I don't have a
bathtub so that's impossible for me yeah
he was like you probably should take a
magnesium supplement right so it's sort
of taking a magnesium glit glycinate
glassy glycinate yeah there'll be links
to both of these in the in the show
notes but but yeah long story short leap
for sure
what's that helps your sleep immensely
yeah so yeah it just helps balance your
body I guess yeah well you know it's
funny man the the I drink this tea at
night I which I've recommended before
it's called um it's like caramel bedtime
tea yogi yeah there's the maker of it
I've been drinking that and this the
Thea nine theanine what does that do
what does something you don't want to do
you said it helps suppress your desire
Coffee is that all is well I have know
what you're recommending some you know I
mean your what is what I'm saying is is
that taking these two supplements in the
morning uh-huh I don't need that second
cup of coffee okay I probably don't need
the first cup of coffee I just like
coffee a lot right
it's such junk but I still have it it is
definitely not JA it and now coffees
junk dude no no it's not it absolutely
I'll put okay I'll put three studies in
the show notes for you this shows an in
enhance cognitive but you can sit about
alcohol - no you can't yes alcohol
absolutely helps you cardiovascular I
just what what there's a oh I'll
recommend this documentary - I just saw
it on Netflix the truth behind alcohol
100% hell it is having a having a small
bit of alcohol every single day
especially for women over 55 years old
absolutely incredibly I believe that I
believe that's true that's the other
thing too is that there are ways to
there are more healthy ways to get the
benefits as what I'm saying not true
with caffeine but but you can get
straight caffeine but there there are
neurocognitive that it's definitely not
junk
it is a nonessential I agree with that
but but in terms of coffee is not an
essential I mean I can pretend it is
because I've loved coffee though right
but but no I've done I've done a lot of
recently if we could all live our lives
without coffee we'd still live helpful
meaningful lives we could still find a
way to totally agree but that that my
point is that there are it's a
non-essential but it can add value to
your life it's not junk for me so yeah
basically those two those two
supplements it just it honestly it just
makes me feel more awake helps me like
added with the alpha brain yeah like
dude I just have more energy so and
that's just me personally uh there could
be a doctor listening of this right now
I'm like you know shoot shoot this down
but even if it's placebo dude it's
totally working on me yeah well in by
the way we are not doctors no before you
make any changes to your diet or
exercise consult your physician yes
absolutely I will recommend the truth
behind alcohol it is a really good it is
a really good documentary on Netflix
right now it just yeah I won't spoil it
there's Elena not that much to spoil but
for the sake of time I'm I won't sit
here and you know give a synopsis of it
but yeah check it out alright cool well
let's move on to our new segment real
quick it's called weight lifting with
the minimalists where we turned the
Twitter we're at the minimalists on
Twitter and we asked what physical item
is weighing you down recently and why
and then we attempt to help you lift the
weight
hat tip to our friend Malcolm Fon ta who
were actually we're working on this this
new bag everyone's been asking like
where do I get that bag that's in your
documentary and it's been the bane of my
existence for the last couple years
since well last year since the
documentary came out everyone's asking
well he's bringing that bag back out and
we're helping him make the bag a little
bit better
it's called packed bags is the name of
the new company he's forming just to
bring out I mean the bag has been
unavailable since 2012 he's doing a
Kickstarter this fall on it and I want
to say thanks he's willing to give us
the idea of doing the weight lifting
with the minimalist segments if you're
interested in that bag I wrote an essay
called keep travel simple you can read
that over at packed bags dot-com now
pack this spelled P akt packed bags calm
I've been told that's the Polish word
for what is a man I'm blanking on what's
the Polish word for I'm gonna google it
yeah I think it's murder-suicide no way
no that's not it as a different act no
is packed PA Cady bags calm and Malcolm
is has that bag coming out and I wrote
an essay called keep travel simple over
there
anyway we're gonna answer one question
here and then Ryan we will do a bonus
episode strictly for our patreon
supporters helping a bunch of folks lift
the weight over there today and you'll
see that come out in your feed the day
after this comes out weight lifting with
the minimalist you do a private podcast
over on patreon but yeah I'm not getting
anything on this and by the way Andrew
Ferguson says that books CDs DVDs are
all weighing him down well duh they're
heavy man they're quite literally I
remember when she got like a thousand
bucks uh - I had two thousand bucks do
you think do you think he's like under a
pile of books and sees this barely has
his hand sticking out he's tweeting
tweeting yeah so here's the thing the
nice thing about books CDs DVDs did a a
TEDx talk and he was talking about like
all the DVDs that people want one
segment he said all the DVDs you had he
said really you you're like gonna watch
the movie again how about you go get a
life and well I don't agree with that
there are some movies that I'll watch a
second time and are I mean they're
movies especially like mahal and drive
that is much better the second time that
you watch it David Lynch film anyway the
truth is that we're not gonna re-watch
or reread the vast majority of those
things that we're holding on to and by
the way even if we want to we have
access to them now
or you don't have to have the physical
artifact in hand you you have access to
streaming or you have access to the
books on an e-reader I could tell you
getting a Kindle for me it was one of
the best things I ever did for my
library because when you know when we go
out on tour Ryan I have 2,000 books with
me right I'm probably more than that on
the Kindle itself and I have access to
an infinite library of books right there
in my hand I don't have to own the
artifacts and by the way it's so much
easier when I'm getting ready to move to
a new place like we're getting ready to
then moving a stock pile of books yeah
so let them go and have access to them
you don't have to have ownership of
those things dude I had I had like I
don't know one of those CD holders that
holds you know hundred or 200 CDs or
something yeah
in addition to your hundred disc changer
yeah throwback I stressed over these CDs
like oh I'm gonna download them all but
cuz this this is what this dude's
thinking right now man I don't want to I
don't want to if even if he has a CD
drive like they can read and write or
you know and put it onto his computer
right which I don't have actually we do
have a company one that the three of us
will like toss back and forth if we
absolutely need one but but it's
stressful thinking about like those 200
CDs okay I have to you know get get a CD
drive that's going to copy this CD to my
computer put it into an mp3 or mp4
format whatever the format is and I've
got to do this and it takes a while to
like do hundred
of CDs that is stressful I cannot tell
you how freeing it was when I signed up
for ten bucks a month well I actually I
started with side of Spotify I think it
was like seven bucks a month I might
have bumped up to ten bucks a month now
but paying seven dollars a month now in
the long run over what thirty years it's
gonna cost a lot of money and you know
they'll cost you a lot less than if you
were buying new CDs every month oh
that's exactly right
and but yeah and that's my point it's
like well it's twofold like yes the
argument could be made like well if they
just put those CDs onto their drive they
would have to spend the seven bucks a
month to access that music well guess
what if that's the only music you want
to access then I would go back to the
Tony Robbins thing and be like dude get
a life there's gonna be more music you
won and it's gonna be more enjoyable for
you to find new music it is for everyone
so you know not only could I get rid of
those you know 200 CDs that I had right
but I was freed from the weight of those
CDs and I could download every single
one of the every single CD that I have
wanted to listen to that I used to have
I can download right um the Beatles for
a while was hard to get ahold of but
even that now is available um and not
only that but the new music that comes
out I don't want to worry about having
like a physical copy of it I can just
again like download it listen to it
stream it whenever I want so dude you
have the technology use it yeah and
they're clearly not adding value to your
life because it's stressing you out
enough that you're willing to send us a
tweet all right we'll move over to
overtime we'll answer a bunch of other
questions on on weightlifting with the
minimalist there's a bunch of other
questions I got here this morning from
folks on Twitter Ryan will answer those
exclusively for our patreon supporters
what else you got for us Ryan all right
finally here are some voicemail comments
and tips from our listeners hi my name
is Hillary praise ACK and I am calling
from Chapel Hill North Carolina my
comment and tip is for the lady who goes
to the thrift stores and buy clothes and
then sells them on Poshmark I'm thinking
that you could put everything for sale
on the app and if it sells get rid of it
and if it doesn't then you can eval
way if you want to keep it or not that
way you're not constantly debating on if
you should keep it or sell it it's
always just up for sale and then it's
kind of out of your hands whether or not
someone else buys it and maybe that will
help you eliminate holding on to a bunch
of clothes that you actually don't
really need or what hi Josh and Ryan
this is Alison from Raleigh North
Carolina and I have a comment and kind
of a tactic that I've been using for an
incentive to purge I know that you guys
really like coffee and so do i and so
recently I've been only using cash to go
to my favorite coffee shops and instead
of going to an ATM when I run low on
cash I think of what I can sell in order
to get more cash so um I know it sounds
kind of weird but it's just like oh well
what what don't I need so that I can get
some coffee that I really enjoy hi Josh
Ryan I was just listening to me non line
episode and the lady who is moving and
has all her books about for her future
self as she mentioned suggestion would
be to donate those to the local library
that she sees herself living in that
area that way she will always have
access to those particular books and if
she's not sure of which book is
temporarily is easier for her and it
makes her feel better take a picture or
a write the list of those books down and
when she needs a new book to pick up she
can go to the library and rent one of
those books
alright y'all that's it for this episode
if you have a question for the
minimalists give us a call for zero six
two one nine seven eight three nine and
you can also send us a voice memo right
from your phone podcast at the
minimalists comm and if you leave here
with just one message we hope it's this
love people and use things because the
opposite never works thanks for
listening y'all we'll see you next time
[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your green oh I bet that you'll
be fine without
[Music]
every little thing that you gotta have
every little thing that you got you
gotta reach for you got a grand oh I bet
that you'll be fine without you
so tell your team
[Music]
you
[Music]